yeah no one watching this video playing
copy copy k double-oh-seven maybe get to
a king's indian my transpositional off a
modern defense will be a modern oh
that's going to see file well that
should be a decent benoni at a very
early night bd7 plate yes it's not quite
clear what blacks plays in the sky in
this position I mean I'm a lot better in
the center he has no b5 yes no whatever
yeah that you can take for a good
position one should be tool it should be
towards probably a little bit better
yeah it takes Bishop takes Knight f6
d500 righty looks pretty bad they cannot
take it because of this diagonal
situation yeah and here I've got a huge
space advantage okay
okay so I just put this on d5 now the
night I guess I wonder steliana Bishop
Ian should be improved to h4 I guess I
could try to trade off g7 not entirely
sure so here i think i will take then
bishop age 4 so that i'm ready to take
this and put the night on to d5 he might
play the ship before in such a situation
but we'll see I mean 95 is not necessary
to play after taking the way it is now
at least I think he's not able to play
d5 to the Sun the first important thing
yeah I thought that wasn't wasn't really
great due to 95 but I'm seen taking you
7am
okay so preparing before maybe a
seagoing night at four hmm like a four
maybe trying to trade yeah this doesn't
threaten anything f2 is covered even
though that isn't annoying piece yeah
for sure I mean I'm happily giving up
the exchange em
he's got beehive now is a super sir
disturbing really
okay I can take Bishop Bishop takes f6
you should takes Bishop chick I think I
can do that I mean I can always
sacrifice on before I on d4 if he goes
there I might as well do it like that
yeah the thing is to explain the finger
take and I wonder now should I play be
five or not is not man probably not
taking should be okay yeah now he is
potentially threatening threatening this
yeah i'm not sure if i should go just be
five here lookie one is also a good move
I'm done Sean into okie one
yeah everything was was good for white
film was difficult to say what what what
I should actually do often the problem n
to find the find the maximum in a good
position what is really the best move
always the interesting one yeah I have
to take it and then you have this maybe
Queenie form so that I'm actually able
to take on b5 threatening I have six in
the meantime I mean something that
Queens the 826 runs into a fork so
interesting i wonder if i should do a
Bab see 5 or yeah maybe in this c5c 67
is coming quite quickly night is pretty
good 25 yeah yeah I can take on his
seven I don't know if this next much
king of age
this is marching this is better ok
screen before movie role takes takes e73
I am stopping the deep one with the king
yeah so I can just take if he goes Queen
deform time worry
create is not possible and I'm
threatening night XD 7 check here route
takes check on a age yes and c8 yes he
doesn't have a check here come on
where's our King is perfectly safe okay
so let's have a look yeah I don't think
I made the best out of this opening
another thing i'm not sure i mean this
is this is sooo close to unplayable for
black it's really really bad benoni no
no color no count applied and queen
doesn't belong here b6 doesn't belong
it's um yeah just pretty bad so I just
centralized stuff yeah here you can play
many things taking is also probably
better for white but this is a typical
way of doing it yeah he almost has to
change and then we get this position if
I was indeed abated oh I mean that was
the kind of the punishment move let's
say but if its most best I don't know
because why is just better what service
the engines suggestion to centralize
everything 2251 I mean like as our time
to prevent the central breaks in the
long run he has zero play himself so no
not entirely sure then the engine
doesn't like that I wasn't completely
convinced yeah I mean I was this roster
again the most the move that looked most
like punishment that it probably wasn't
all that great yeah Bishop d7 neighs got
the bishop disabled is it would peace
now it was probably not the right way to
do it in here engine clanks equal Knight
f6 yeah to be honest I always thought
that if I get this here that I'm I'm
quite okay is it really good for black
surprised actually so I mean it's always
tied down to that and i thought i'm
always able to set the exchange now i
can go be five in my sins so that
wouldn't be good 93 is the engine
suggestion interesting we're going back
and forth base again nidec forth again
good hmm Jeff now at my doubts during
the game that really wasn't that that
wasn't good here is just all 36 stuff
yeah yeah I'm fine again I just screamed
e6 and saw the body but this is also
look very tempting to five and then take
one day for hmm ok actually have taken
on this side first and as the engine
suggested and this is correct down here
i was thinking here i thought that i
should win this the sea point is
basically just marching yeah I saw that
yes I didn't see a win here oh I can see
25 Wow huge fire Wow and now it's
written both ah that is interesting that
that's made it's a dual made threat Wow
okay yes I i chose the pedestrian way
but it yes it does work yeah so like e6
was a good job it was much better too
much better to probably absorb probably
an English
just centralized yeah it's probably
better he doesn't have any decent porn
break and I can just improve ed whaler
activated him with this point 36 ok guys
thanks for watching